Good friends at gibbons wrote of ancient
Rome that the devout polytheists,
though finally attached to his national
rights,
admitted with implicit faith,
the different religions of the earth,
fear,
gratitude,
and curiosity,
a dream or an omen,
the singular disorder or a distant
journey perpetually disposed him to
multiply the articles of his belief and
to enlarge the list of his protectors.
Holly theism is a chaotic and
historically beautiful condition.
It's not so hard to imagine our
forefathers of antiquity devoid as they
were of explanations for earthquakes or
debilitating diseases stars.
It's not so hard to imagine them
assigning these mysterious forces a
percentage,
a deity,
of what else distinctly human shape and
character whose job it was to oversee
this or that sphere of existence.
This way of thinking is called
[inaudible],
in which the world and its forces are
described by stories of holy origin.
When the mythical man wants to explain
the universe,
he does it based on God's and powers,
and if he is a more elegant thinker in
fiction and allegory,
the worldview of mythos and polytheism
is necessarily disordered and archaic.
There need be no unifying principle to
connect things because the universe as
such is at the caprices of these gods
and goddesses who to read the poetry
about them agree about as much as we
human story.
No.
Now there's
one institution that can exist in a
world dominated exclusively by Mythos,
and that is the institution of science.
Why?
Well,
because we know that the foundational
principle of science is the principle of
no contradiction.
In other words,
it's scientific theory is only valid
until a contradiction is found.
In which case set theory must be revised
or scrapped.
Nothing in polytheism resembles this
kind of logic.
Contradiction in mythos is totally
acceptable,
so we're.
Does science come from well,
this is perhaps the greatest irony of
all science proceeds historically from
monotheism,
a belief system held originally by the
Jews,
that there was one all powerful God from
who's massive.
Mine comes.
The uniform ordered universe makes
sense,
doesn't it?
For Science to work,
it must assume that the universe is
organized by a unifying principle and
idea that doesn't appear until the early
sixth century BC when exiled Jews in
Babylon begin the process of redacting
the many texts of the Hebrew tradition
into what became the old testament was
failing as a pre socratic Malaysian
philosopher of the same era who saw that
such a reduction,
the singular texts and the singular God
it described suggested the principle of
no contradiction.
If God created a universe,
then it had to be ordered and uniform
and so in the person of families and the
subsequent socratic thinkers,
the famous transitioned from myths.
Those two logos takes place.
Logos is a way of explanation
concentrated around argument,
what aristotle later formalizes as logic
in which an or can be brought around to
the other side of a logical disputes
simply by being shown the contradiction
in his argument.
It's humbling to know the close causal
historical connection between monotheism
and modern science.
That connection modern scientists are
low dimension.
The truth is that science is as firmly
rooted in belief as religion.
It cannot work without the assumption
that the universe is ordered and follows
the rule of no contradiction like
science says it does.
Now,
as a postscript,
you may be asking yourself,
does this mean that religion is as valid
and epistemological system as sciences?
They are both based on belief.
Well,
there is a very simple answer for that.
No
city.
The city.